la vie des noirs comptent montréal
continue elle aussi de le répéter aux
efforts des jeunes des noirs des blancs
qui réclament la justice la fin du
profilage racial de la brutalité
policière
la fin du racisme nous on est humble on
n'a jamais eu à définir de notre couleur
n'ai jamais dit à se battre pour ça on a
eu les droits mais les droits on aimait
comme ça pourquoi les autres ont volé
les mêmes droits que nous sommes assis
unis pour les générations futures des
familles venues éduquer leurs enfants
c'est important que mes enfants et ils
comprennent ce mouvement le un mouvement
qui prend de l'ampleur partout
à québec ils se sont agenouillés à la
mémoire de john floyd à sherbrooke aussi
en ontario c'était la troisième journée
consécutive de manifestations pacifiques
parce que le racisme est partout et
c'est justement le message qu'ils
avaient pour les politiciens entre
autres françois legault c'est le goal
sallent son histoire aujourd'hui nous
sommes là juste pour nous faire
respecter
on a tous des québécois nous les noirs
puis les autres communautés minoritaires
en vue du racisme au quotidien pizza
depuis que je suis née machenaud québec
depuis que je suis née je vis du racisme
à l'école dans les marchés maintenant
tout futur à ce prix ça peut pas changer
certains politiciens se sont engagés à
aller au delà des promesses beaucoup de
la limo au delà de la manifestation
aujourd'hui au delà des belles paroles
ou de la danse jamais il est content il
faut arrêter de mettre sur pied des
comités bidon qui ne servent à rien il y
est temps maintenant depuis faire juste
des plans d'actions mis de passer à
l'action
d'abord une volonté politique des gestes
concrets qu'ils ont bien l'intention de
continuer à réclamer issigeac audrey
charbonneau raid au canada montréal